Anie Samson et Luc Ferrandez
bonsoir.
- Bonsoir.
- Je vous montre les candidats à
l'aval parce qu'on ne va pas
parler que de Montréal lors de
ce panel. Stéphane Boyer, avec
les premiers espaces verts,
Michel Trottier Tea Party la
balle et Sophie Trottier
d'Action Laval. J'imagine qu'ils
ne sont pas parents tous les
deux. Je reviens à la promesse
de Monsieur Boyer, c'est le
genre de promesse que vous
devrez aimer Luc Ferrandez.
- C'est excellent et il faut le
faire. Il a tellement raison.
C'est un projet enthousiasmant.
L'inverseur est inadmissible,
mais quand même, petit bémol
regardant les chiffres. La balle
à trois par nature qui totalise
60 ha. L'administration
d'Emerson HT 40 au coût de 35
millions. Il propose d'en
ajouter 500. C'est
extraordinaire. 5 x 5 les
espaces nature.
- Les gens que vous régnez
faire.
- Ça va se faire aussi à
Montréal. On va acheter le
séjour. Mais même en faisant
cela, 500 ha, il arrive à 600
ha. À Montréal, une île beaucoup
plus grosse, 3000 lecteurs sont
préservés. La balle avait un
énorme déficit d'espaces nature
ils prennent une très grosse
bouchée et espérons qu'ils vont-
ils arriver. Il reste 18 boisées
sur Lille il faut les protéger.
Il faut protéger les golfs. Il
ne faut pas faire de changement
de zonage sur les golfs.
Il faut protéger les berges
comme ils vont le faire. Les
milieux humides aussi.
- Année.
- Je suis convaincu que ça va
être super projet. Je connais
très bien l'endroit et c'est une
excellente nouvelle pour les
Lavallois. 550 ha, c'est pas mal
plus grand que Central Park.
C'est beaucoup plus grand que le
Mont-Royal. À Laval, un tiers de
leur territoire et à terre
avant. C'était les terres
agricoles. Il est le passage de
mère que je n'aimerais pas qui a
développé beaucoup. Je vois
enfin cette lumière avec ce
jeune candidat à la mairie qui
représente une nouvelle
génération, donc celle qui vient
après la nôtre, le qui est moi.
Celle-là
- moi aussi.
- Ils veulent protéger et ont
une vie pour l'avenir. Ce projet
est un projet extrêmement
important.
- Je veux qu'on revoit les trois
photos des candidats. Quel genre
de lutte vous entrevoyait à
Laval? Est-ce que Boyer, comme
il a l'appui du maire sortant
par avec une grande avance?
- Le maire Demers un bilan des
deux dernières années il a
acquis deux ha pour le chemin de
l'équerre ils ont un bilan
intéressant et positif. Il faut
se rappeler pourquoi Marc Demers
est arrivé. Il est arrivé pour
faire du ménage dans la ville et
se départir du passé de l'ancien
maire. Il repart et laisse la
jeunesse prend la place.
- Luc, Laval, une longueur
d'avance pour Boyer?
- Il faut mettre une partie des
surplus de Laval pour qu'on
continue le projet et pages et
10 %. Pour l'instant, ça va
dépendre, le projet de la ville
verte et bleue. Ces dessins qui
arrivent au compte-gouttes. Est-
ce que le projet va être sur 25
ou 50 ans? Est-ce qu'on peut le
faire plus rapidement? Je
m'attendais engagement concret.
Du côté de Boyer, c'est la mise
à niveau de l'urbanisme de
Laval. La réflexion sur le
recommencement... c'est aussi ue
grande avancée qui n'avait
jamais été faite à Laval à cause
de la présence d'autres marins
vendus. Beaucoup de beaux
projets. Il faut que les
oppositions extrêmes. Le
meilleur gagne.
- M. Coderre, on en avait parlé
ensemble, la question de la
hauteur des gratte-ciels. Il
jongle avec l'idée de permettre
aux promoteurs de dépasser le
Mont-Royal et je vous fais
écouter Monsieur Coderre qui dit
que ce n'est pas une très bonne
idée finalement.
- Quand j'ai parlé du Mont-
Royal, j'ai provoqué un débat.
Il y a des gens qui montrent que
ça dépend de la perspective
qu'on est et où on se place.
Qu'est-ce que ça veut dire la
hauteur du Mont-Royal?
- J'imagine que c'était encore
plus clair. Vous riez, Luc.
- Bravo de reculer.
Félicitations. Les villes n'ont
pas besoin de mur de béton en
hauteur. Ça en prend de la
hauteur mais il ne faut pas
avoir des corridors d'immeuble
sans perte de soleil.
Il y a des projets qui m'ont
fait peur. Bravo. Sa façon de
reculer, c'est amusant.
- Vous connaissez bien Monsieur
Coderre Annie. Il met la touche
finale à son programme. Il veut
enlever des sujets qui
pourraient être controversés.
- J'ai aussi son livre et j'ai
pris le temps de relire ce
passage où on parlait de la
hauteur. Et j'ai relu le
communiqué qu'il a émis
aujourd'hui et j'ai des doutes.
Il va falloir que les
montréalais soient révélés gens
parce que quand on dit qu'on
veut augmenter et on veut faire
de l'urbanisme et augmenter la
densité d'une façon douce et
intelligente, qu'est-ce que ça
veut dire? On dit qu'on est pas
d'accord avec le 20-20-20 parce
que c'est trop rigide. Tout
cela, il faut que se construire,
je me pose des questions. Est-ce
que c'est juste parce que c'est
la campagne électorale et le
lendemain de l'élection, on va
recommencer à faire ça? Les
électeurs, soyez présent et
soyez là dans les consultations
et soyez assuré que ça se passe
bien. Douce et intelligente,
j'ai un peu de difficulté avec
un programme électoral.
- Tu as tout à fait raison. Ce
n'est pas la vision complète.
Au-delà de Will à hauteur on va
la diminuer, quelle est sa
vision centre-ville? Le vieux
Montréal... comment il va
densifier de façon intelligente
et de façon humaine et de façon
urbaniste?
- Merci beaucoup. C'est to